wake up wake up wake up wake up up you  wake up you wake up you wake up your way  universe  our neighbors nice now well she doesn't  forgive me thing or we get too noisy  just talk to me you talk to Pete  hi we're hosting a birthday for ask your  party you guys are throwing out a little  bit of party  let's make sure if we're too noisy call  me first okay okay  it's time to shut it down can't be  serious this is a great party gonna shut  it down or I'm calling the cops your  hands behind your head  you caught about amazing you know we  thought the cops evaluated the circle  address pocket we're sorry we call the  cops okay you have no idea what you  started  welcome to the darkness business  I'm telling you these people are  Satanists as I sit here they are saying  as a potato  but into the console oh the  dude mr. Ayer BAM  they do estimators  I don't want to take the gloves off  toilet a come on  there goes the neighborhood